we are honored to welcome Victor Davis
Hanson a senior fellow at the Hoover
institution I'm one of the smartest
people we know Professor thanks so much
for joining us so I think it's pretty
clear where we are how we got here what
next
well unfortunately Tucker we had a
midterm referendum on the Biden
Administration and they not only didn't
articulate what they were doing they
didn't defend it and worse yet
they didn't promise to change and so
they look at the referendum the midterms
and they think you know what
inflation oil prices we didn't even talk
about instead we called our enemies
semi-fascists we said they were on
American we said women were dying all
over the the country when they can't get
abortions and that was a successful
formula so we're going to do what we did
before we're going to double down on it
we would rather be ideologically correct
than worry about the American people the
middle class this is exactly what he
promised on the campaign Trail in 2020
he said he was going to eliminate fossil
fuel he just picked up the Mantra from
Barack Obama who said he was going to
make electricity prices Skyrocket when
he shut down coal and Stephen Chu the
designate an energy secretary in 2008
said he wanted European high prices I
think we got to get acculturated the
fact that this as you said was
deliberate it's going to continue and
they see it as a great a great good
they're never subject to the
consequences of their own ideology and
they feel we still stupid middle class
people don't know what's good for us
they do and we've got to go down this
Green Road into Oblivion and every once
in a while when they get close to an
election they can tap the Strategic
petroleum Reserve or they can out get
about half a trillion dollar student
loan amnesty and then after the midterms
are over we'll hear about all the
layoffs or the Bitcoin collapse of Mr
bankman freed and then they can continue
put in a little banding on the wood
until the next election but they're not
going to change unfortunately
no they're not going to change and I
think that's the key Insight right there
they're not going to change they're not
and and voters didn't force us to do the
cycle unfortunately everything you've
articulated
Tucker is absolutely true but they
wouldn't disagree with you they would
say yes this is the this is the cost of
transitioning to a green future and
there's going to be some damage it's not
going to be us at a hurt but they're not
they're not ashamed they're not
apologetic yeah until they ban private
air travel I'm not listening to a word
they say and I mean that Victorious
Hanson great to see you tonight thank
you so much subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight